how's it going everybody it's Warren and
I'm very excited today to tell you that
I have a DC exclusive scoop for you this
scoop comes from Mikey Sutton and I'm
fortunate enough that he gave the scoop
to me to release to the public so big
shout out to Mikey there today scoop
involves Deathstroke that's right the
famous villain that fans have been
waiting to see in the DC Universe for a
very long time now especially after he
was teased at the end of Justice League
what is next for this villain when are
we going to see him enter the DC
Universe I'll talk about the entire
scoop in this video I'm still giving
away an Xbox one or a ps4 so be sure to
subscribe to my channel like the video
and leave a comment below to enter the
giveaway so again this comes from Mikey
Sutton he has provided a lot of super
hero scoops lately to the community and
today we are talking about Deathstroke a
Deathstroke film has been dead and alive
at Warner Brothers Studios will they or
won't they that's been the question when
it comes to adapting Slade Wilson to the
silver screen but with Warner Brothers
Studios recently cutting ties with Ben
Affleck and the Snider vision of the DC
EU that included Joe Manganiello lumped
into the trash heap of memory his
chances of going solo for a theatrical
adventure has been a question mark only
two years ago the raids Gareth Evans was
attached to the movie but now we are
hearing that Deathstroke is most wanted
for television after debuting on DC
universes Titans with acai Morales in
the role there is talk of Deathstroke
having his own TV series as well
alongside of Titans as it is the same
with Titans the death stroke program
will be for it mature audiences dark and
violent Deathstroke is an extremely
popular character one who appeals to the
edgy corners of the comic dumb like The
Punisher and Wolverine and while
Deathstroke might not flex enough
box-office muscle for IMAX theaters he
is potentially hot stuff for binge
watching right now we are hearing that
the discussions for this are still in
the early stage and nobody has said that
Morales has been approached for an
extended run however this Deathstroke
series is looking quite likely to happen
again fans were very excited to see
Deathstroke after his tease in the
Justice League and no doubt some fans
will be disappointed that we won't be
seeing him on the big screen however him
getting his own TV series makes a lot of
sense
and this news comes at the same
time that DC has announced that they are
going to be taken to Green Lantern to a
TV series as well on HBO max and right
now it kind of seems like the
Deathstroke situation is the same as the
Green Lantern was we were originally
supposed to be getting a new film from
DC the Green Lantern Corps but obviously
as of yesterday we have discovered that
they are not in fact doing this film but
they are moving it to HBO max so now it
appears like we are going to be getting
the same thing with Deathstroke however
it is unclear on whether or not the
Deathstroke series would be on HBO max
or on DC Universe but it does make sense
that it would be on DC Universe so that
it could be in the same universe as
Titans so as of right now it is looking
very likely that we're going to be
getting a Deathstroke series coming very
soon do you like this news or do you
think that we should be getting a movie
let me know your thoughts down below and
also don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof